[Musique]
vous invitez pour comprendre ce budget
se soient remis à mme sy qui est pdg de
l'institut du québec et luc godbout qui
est titulaire de la chaire de recherche
en fiscalité et en finances publiques de
l'université de sherbrooke bonsoir à
vous deux mon sort je m'entendais bien
oui parfait excellent me m6 je vais
commencer avec vous repoussez le déficit
zéro à 2028 28 ans veut la loi sur
l'équilibré budgétaire là est ce que
c'est la chose à faire selon vous oui
c'est la chose à faire puis je serais
bien mal placé sur le contraire parce
qu'avec l'association des économistes
québécois le québec on ne réunit
plusieurs experts puis tout le monde a
abondé dans cette direction là pourquoi
ne pas prendre un peu plus de temps
commençons par sortir de la pandémie ne
pas nuire à la relance et on pourra dans
sept ans est à l'équilibré budgétaire en
plus la loi tient compte de versements
au fonds des générations dans cet
équilibre budgétaire
le service de la dette nous coûte moins
cher à cause des faibles taux
l'endettement donc est sous contrôle et
stabilisé même en baisse donc et
honnêtement c'était la chose à faire ce
qu'un équilibre entre protéger les
services produire à la relance à court
terme mais quand même retrouver
l'équilibré budgétaire éventuellement
parce qu'on a d'autres défis qui s'en
viennent que des risques d'inflation de
hausse de taux et erreurs on se rappelle
tous sur le goût de books et lucien
bouchard bernard landry qui avait adopté
la loi sur l'équilibré budgétaire pour
nous ramener vraiment après un déficit à
l'intérieur de cinq ans l équilibre
budgétaire suspendre la loi pour prendre
sept ans selon vous c est ce que c'est
une bonne chose à faire
ben oui un peu comme bio nous dès le
mois d'août septembre dernier on avait
un symposium sur les finances publiques
et on proposait ont proposé de changer
la loi ont proposé de changer la loi
pour en fonction de l'ampleur des
récessions d'avoir en trois et sept ans
pour retrouver l'équilibré budgétaire
donc le 7 ans nous satisfait cela dit on
aurait préféré changer la loi plutôt que
la suspendre
saleh sont un peu d'ambiguïté lorsque la
loi est suspendu et dont il va falloir
négocier que les partis politiques
nous on aurait préféré la stabiliser en
mettant des critères plus
plus précis à l'intérieur même de cette
voie là comment expliquer l'écart à
résorber 2,6 milliards 500 millions qui
est identifié à 27,28 parce que le
gouvernement dit on reviendra à
l'équilibré en 27 28 mais il faut encore
trouver 6 milliards 500 millions
nuxe ac c'est déficit structurel c'est
le déficit structurel le ministre se
plaît à nommer nous on est content parce
que c'est un débat qui était pas souvent
menés sur la place publique un sujet
donc un déficit structurel
ça veut dire qu'il ne peut pas se
résorber de lui même il faut faire des
gestes pour le résorber des justes par
plus de croissance économique des gestes
par des augmentations d'impôts je sais
que ça plaira pas aux gens ou des gestes
par le ralentissement des dépenses
augmentations d'impôts au ralentissement
des dépenses à peut s'apparenter à de
l'austérité
dépendamment de l'ampleur avec lequel on
le fait on en est pas encore là
il n'y a pas de street en vue pour le
moment je veux rassurer tout le monde
mais pour combler ce déficit structurel
là il va falloir poser des gestes
est ce que c'est important me ya un
écart à résorber 2,6 milliards 500
millions dans le budget de l'état du
québec c'est c'est énorme le ça
ressemble à ce qu'on a dû résorber en
2008 puis pour le faire on a dû
accroître le fardeau fiscal on se
rappellera la tvq la taxe sur l'essence
hausse du bloc patrimonial les tarifs
d'hydroélectricité donc eu plusieurs
mesures puis après il ya eu un
ralentissement de la croissance des
dépenses assez abrupte donc oui ça se
fait pas tout seul 6.5 milliards mais
l'on se donne cinq ans pour le faire
donc en partie année après année vu que
c'est loin ya peut-être la croissance
économique pour nous un 10/10 cela ne
peut être ottawa il ya peut-être des
marges de manoeuvre qui vont se dégager
au fur et à mesure que la situation va
se clarifier mais chose certaine il va
falloir qui est quelque part des choix
importants soit en compression de
service soit aux deux fardeau fiscal je
pense que c'est un débat qu'on on pourra
pas s'en sort mais pas avant les
élections de toute évidence qui s'en
viennent dans un an et demi
l'udc avant le versements au fonds des
générations
on arrive dans les faits l équilibre dès
2024 pratiquement 25 26 sinon est ce
qu'on devrait suspendre temporairement
aussi les versements au fonds des
général
ma réponse serait non
si on affronte avec autant de sérénité
la crise d'abord démis actuelle c'est
parce que là la loi sur l'équilibré
budgétaire mais la loi portant création
du fonds des générations ont assaini les
finances publiques du québec on est en
meilleure santé financière et c'est pour
ça que le ministre peut affronter ça
avec un peu plus de sérénité
la seule ouverture qui pourrait y avoir
certains versements dédié au fonds des
générations pour être temporairement
suspendu et encore une fois moi j'irai
directement dans la loi je dirais pour
2,3 en voici le versement x y ou z qui
devrait être suspendu et que de manière
automatique la loi par la suite
réintègre ses versements là pour
continuer de verser au fonds des
générations
est ce que moi j'ai l'impression en
regardant le budget aujourd'hui que
c'est un budget de transition c'est à
dire on à la fin de la pandémie faut
aider les gens puis on à la relance en
même temps puis on parle de relance dans
ça est-ce que mia vous diriez consentent
les actions aujourd'hui vraiment sur les
bons points sur les missions
essentielles santé éducation
moi je trouve que oui parce que dans le
fond il y avait un grand piège qu'il
fallait que le gouvernement évite qu'ils
s'étaient de rajouter de l'huile sur le
feu ça veut dire des mesures un peu
injuste il électoraliste ronde saupoudre
un peu d'argent à tout le monde
on n'a pas besoin de ça parce que là la
croissance les nouvelles prévisions qui
sortent par les institutions les
macroéconomistes les prévisionnistes
c'est très très élevé il on parle de 6%
de croissance du pib réel mais 8 9% de
nominal
les revenus sont influencés par le
nominal on veut surtout pas stimuler la
consommation davantage qu'on veut c'est
aider les gens qui en ont besoin que
sont encore frappé qui sont encore
vulnérables les secteurs touchés
ce faux pas les abandonner c'est
fondamental je pense que ya des gestes
en ce sens là et on concentre les
dépenses sur la santé l'éducation
c'est l'ocde importants besoins de la
santé on n'est pas sorti du tout du tout
du tout du bois puis l'éducation va voir
de plus en plus les réponses et l'impact
lieu que je vais regarder avec vous
certaines mesures qui touchent les gens
les jeunes les aînés
d'abord on bonifie aujourd'hui le crédit
d'impôt pour le maintien à domicile des
personnes depuis
soixante dix oui c'est un crédit qui
existe depuis une vingtaine d'années
mais il ya déjà été bonifié à plusieurs
reprises dans le fond le taux du crédit
et de 35%
on le fait pas c'est plus un taux un
point par année donc on passe à
progressivement 36 à 37 à 38 à 39
jusqu'à atteindre 40%
donc le taux du crédit à terme va être
de 40 % et c'est c'est le premier
changement ce qui donne comme vous
montrer avec vos calculs donc pour un
ménage de personnes âgées 70 ans et plus
on avance avant la réforme on aurait
3290 attrait la réforme complète une
fois que le taux sera à 40 pour ça on
aura droit à quatre cent soixante dix
dollars de plus la réforme du crédit
pour métier à domicile apporte d'autres
changements on on avait déjà pour les
personnes autonomes une réduction du
montant selon notre revenu donc si on
avait des revenus plus élevés on avait
moins on maintient cette logique les de
la réduction mais on accélère pour les
ménages qui font plus de 100000 donc ça
moi je me poserai pas ça c'était dans la
commission d'examen sur la fiscalité
d'accélérer la décroissance de ce crédit
de là pour cibler ceux qui en avaient le
plus besoin donc la logique et est
maintenu mais pour les personnes non
autonomes on bonifie hocine crédit
jusqu'à 40% et c'est seulement la
portion bonification qui pourrait faire
l'objet d'une réduction si les revenus
sont élevés le reste du crédit n'est pas
un sujet la réduction les jeunes auront
droit à des versements particulier pour
les sessions de l'automne 2020 de
l'hiver 2021 et on élimine aussi pour un
an les intérêts sur les prêts étudiants
mais là on note que c'est un cadeau aux
jeunes pour la session 2020 elle est
déjà faite l'on va recevoir 100 $ pour
une cession déjà fait
même chose pour la session d'hiver on
est déjà inscrits on va recevoir 1 100 $
et aussi à partir du 1er avril 2021 pour
toute l'année jusqu'au 31 mars 2022
il ya élimination des intérêts sur les
prêts étudiants
ça veut dire que comme étudiant si vous
avez déjà en train de ex étudiant vous
êtes en train de rembourser votre prêt
le remboursement va se faire au même tôt
qu'à l'habitude ou même montant
versements mensuels mais il valait plus
versés à rembourser le capital parce que
le gouvernement pour payer pour vous les
intérêts si vous
une réduction de vos paiements mensuels
va falloir contacter directement votre
institution financière ayant une baisse
d'impôts pour les pme duc
ben oui donc les pme le taux pourrait
passer de 4 à trois points 2 % et donc
c'est une réduction qui commence au
prorata à partir de demain
donc à partir de demain tous les
entreprises qui ont des fins d'année
financière vont voir au prorata la
réduction du taux jusqu'à avoir une
pleine année à trois points 2 % on se
rappelle que pour les pme elles
pourraient avoir droit ce taux là il
faut avoir cinq mille cinq cents heures
donc pourquoi ne pas que les
professionnels incorporé puisse
bénéficier du taux pme le lion rajouter
un choix comme lieu de moins d'heures
travaillées dans les pme à cause de la
pandémie à cause du confinement
il laisse le choix aux pme de dire si
pour l'année l'année si vos heures de
l'année précédente vous qualifiez vous
allez continuer d'être qualifié à cette
réduction de taux pour bénéficier du
nouveau taux
mia est ce que est ce qu on touche les
bonnes cibles sur le plan économique les
pme avec la baisse d'impôts on parle
beaucoup des régions dans le budget on
parle de tourisme
j'ai vu des bourses aussi pour les
étudiants en technologie de
l'information
un crédit d'impôt aussi pour les
entreprises qui veulent investir en
nouvelles technologies qui est d'oublier
jusqu'à la fin de 2022
est-ce qu'on va aider structurellement
l'économie avec tout ça oui je pense ça
va dans la bonne direction on aurait
peut-être pu peser un peu plus sur les
mesures d'information et elle est un
petit peu plus fort pour vraiment
s'assurer qu'on répond adéquatement aux
enjeux de pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui
sont très très très lié à là à la
reprise le passé déjà un frein ya déjà
énormément de postes vacants dans
l'économie donc j'aurai peut-être mieux
avoir un peu plus sur les mesures de
formation en lien avec les mesures de
développement économique
mais sinon oui je pense que tout ce qui
est nouvelle économie virage numérique
pme c'est très important parce ça va
nous permettre de prendre le virage qui
a été accélérée pendant la crise et
aussi d'avoir plus de revenus peut-être
plus d avoir des choix - du style dans
quelques années j'en perdais messieurs
legault il ya quelques jours dire aux
étudiants
allez en technologie plomb qu'on prend
dans le budget parce qu'il ya des
mesures justement pour encourager les
étudiants à étudier en technologies de
l'information est ce qu'on touche à la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre ici oui parce
que dans le fond le virage numérique
dont on parle c'est pas juste acheter
des équipements mais c'est s'assurer que
les gens ont les compétences les
qualifications nécessaires pour prendre
ce virage là puis c'est pas juste
certains secteurs le secteur des
technologies c'est de plus en plus de
transversales à travers tous les
secteurs même nom secteurs qui ont été
très affecté le commerce en ligne et le
télétravail tout ça ça a accéléré
c'est vraiment des changements
structurels de l'économie le reste de la
planète les princes de virages lents
donc oui c'est bon d'encourager les
jeunes à les hanter i parce que peu
importe le secteur dans lequel il veut
travailler va falloir être plus
numérique transferts en santé je termine
là dessus le goût de boue ont
heureusement le pot mais on l'a pas
intégré dans le budget par ce qui n'est
pas du tout clair combien on va avoir en
matière de transferts en santé mais on
dit quand même que ce serait bien pour
revenir à l'équilibré
c'est sûr que c'est un facteur et dans
ceux où on est le ministre des finances
de recevoir des milliards additionnels
du côté d'ottawa
cela dit il ya une vingtaine d'années on
parlait de déséquilibre fiscal on disait
les besoins sont dans les provinces et
l'argent est à ottawa
maintenant on est obligé de dire les
besoins sont peut-être dans les
provinces mais l'argent n'est pas
d'avoir l'argent dans la poche des
contribuables et que ça soit le
gouvernement fédéral ou gouvernement
dessus des provinces va falloir aller la
chercher de cette façon là si on veut
plus de services publics se le dire
aujourd'hui la menace des finances à
l'annoncé des bonifications de
transferts fédéraux ponctuelles pour la
prochaine année
mais c'est loin de la demande de l'adam
prudential des provinces
la dame prudent à ottawa oui ok elle
annoncé environ 7 milliards pour des
transferts pour les provinces pour les
prochaines années
ok très bien on y reviendra de toute
façon puis lui que vous serez avec nous
non seulement pour la spéciale impôts du
31 mars qu'on fait ensemble toujours en
collaboration avec l'université de
sherbrooke
mais on sera en forme aussi le 19 avril
mia on se retrouve plein de choix comme
d'habitude et avec bonheur merci à vous
deux merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit